the thousand-made theory says that
basically every cortical column
in the in your neural cortex is a
complete modeling system
and that when i ask where do i have a
model of something like a coffee cup
it's not in one of those models it's in
thousands of those models there's
thousands of models of coffee cups
that's what the thousand brains there's
a voting mechanism then there's a voting
mechanism which leads which
is the thing you're which you're
conscious of which leads to your
singular perception
um that's why you you perceive something
so that's the thousand brain theory
the details how we got to that theory
um are complicated it wasn't you just
thought of it one day
and one of those details is we had to
ask how does a model make predictions
and we've talked about just these
predictive neurons
that's part of this theory it's like
saying oh it's a detail but
it was like a crack in the doors like
how are we going to figure out how these
neurons build do this you know what is
going on here
so we just looked at prediction as like
well we know that's ubiquitous we know
that every part of the cortex is making
predictions
therefore whatever the predictive system
is it's going to be everywhere
we know there's a gazillion predictions
happening at once so let's see if we can
start teasing apart
you know ask questions about you know
how could neurons be making these
predictions and that
sort of built up to now what we have the
thousand brains theory
which is complex you know it's just some
i can state it simply but we just didn't
think of it
we had to get there step by step very it
took years
uh to get there and where does uh
reference frames fit in so yeah
okay so again a reference frame i
mentioned
um earlier about the you know model of a
house and i said if you're going to
build a model of a house
in a computer they have a reference
frame and you can then reference them
like
cartesian coordinates like x y and z
axes
so i could say oh well i'm going to
design a house i can say well the
the front door is at this location xyz
and the roof is at this location xyz and
so on
that's a type of reference frame so it
turns out
for you to make a prediction and i walk
you through the thought experiment in
the book where i was
predicting what my finger was going to
feel when i touched the coffee cup
it was a ceramic coffee cup but this one
will do um
and what i realized is that to make a
prediction with my finger's going to
feel like it's just going to feel
different than this which would feel
different if i touch the hole or the
thing on the bottom
make that prediction the cortex needs to
know where the finger is the tip of the
finger
relative to the coffee cup and exactly
relative to the coffee cup
and to do that i have to have a
reference frame for the car pickup it
has to have a way of representing the
location of my finger
to the coughing up and then we realize
of course every part of your skin has to
have a reference frame relative things
and such and then we
did the same thing with vision but so
the idea that a reference frame
is necessary to make a prediction when
you're touching something or when you're
seeing something
and you're moving your eyes you're
moving your fingers it's just a
requirement
to know what to predict if i have a if i
have a structure i'm going to make a
prediction i have to
i have to know where it is i'm looking
or touching it
so then we say well how do neurons make
reference frames it's not obvious
you know xyz coordinates don't exist in
the brain it's just not the way it works
so that's when we looked at the older
part of the brain the hippocampus and
the antaranna cortex
where we knew that in that part of the
brain
there's a reference frame for a room or
reference name for environment
remember i talked earlier about how you
could know make a map of this room
so we said oh that they are implementing
reference frames there so
we knew that reference frames needed to
exist in every cortical column
and so that was a deductive thing we
just deduced it
has to go so you take the old
mammalian ability to know where you are
in a particular space
and you start applying that to higher
and higher levels yeah you first you
apply it to physical like where your
finger is
so here's what i think about it the old
part of the brain says where's my body
in this room
yeah the new part of the brain says
where's my finger
relative to this this object yeah where
is
the a section of my retina relative to
this object like where where is
i'm looking at one little corner where
is that relative to this patch of my
retina yeah
um and then we take the same thing and
apply it to concepts
mathematics physics you know humanity
whatever you want to think of country
you're pondering your own mortality
well whatever but the point is when we
think about the world when we have
knowledge about the world how is that
knowledge organized
lex where do you where is it in your
head the answer is it's in reference
frames
so the way i learn the structure of this
water bottle
where the features are relative to each
other when i think about history or
democracy or mathematics
the same basic underlying structures
happening there's reference frames for
where the knowledge
that you're assigning things to so in
the book i go through examples like
mathematics
and language and politics but
the evidence is very clear in the
neuroscience the same mechanism that we
use to model this coffee cup we're going
to use to model
high level thoughts your your your
demise of the humanity whatever you want
to think about
it's interesting to think about how
different are the representations of
those
higher dimensional concepts
higher level concepts how different the
representation there is in terms of
reference frames
versus spatial but interesting thing
it's it's
it's a different application but it's
the exact same mechanism
but isn't there some aspect to uh
higher level concepts that they seem to
be hierarchical
like they just seem to integrate a lot
of information into so
is our physical objects so take this
water bottle
uh i'm not particular to this brand but
this is a fiji water bottle
and it has um a logo on i use this
example in my book
our our company's coffee cup has a logo
on it but
this object is hierarchical it is
it's got like a cylinder and a cap but
then has this logo on it and the logo
has a word the word has letters the
letters have different features
and so i don't have to remember i don't
think about this so i said oh there's a
fiji logo on this water bottle i don't
have to go through and say
oh what is the fiji logo it's the f and
i and the j and i and there's a hibiscus
flower and
and uh oh it has the pest you know the
stamen on it i don't have to do that i
just incorporate all of that
in some sort of hierarchical
representation i say um
you know put this logo on this water
bottle yeah and
and and then the logo has a word and the
word has letters
all hierarchical just all that stuff is
big it's amazing that the brain
instantly just does all that yeah the
idea that there's there's water it's
liquid and the idea that you can
drink it when you're thirsty the idea
that there's brands yeah
and then there's like all of that
information is instantly
like built into the whole thing once you
proceed so i wanted to get back to your
point about hierarchical representation
the world itself is hierarchical
right and i can take this microphone in
front of me i know inside there's going
to be some electronics i know there's
going to be some wires and i know
there's going to be a little
diaphragm that moves back and forth i
don't see that but i know it
so everything in the world is
hierarchical you just go into room it's
composed of other components the kitchen
has a refrigerator you know
the computer has a door the door has a
hinge the hinge has screws and pin yeah
i mean
so anyway the the the modeling system
that exists in every cortical column
learns the hierarchical structure of
objects
so it's a very sophisticated modeling
system in this grain of rice it's hard
to imagine but this grain of ice can do
really sophisticated things it's got a
hundred thousand neurons in it
um it's very sophisticated so
that same mechanism that can model a
water bottle or a coffee cup can model
conceptual objects as well
it's if that's the beauty of this
discovery that this guy vernon mount
castle made many many years ago which is
that
there's there's a single cortical
algorithm underlying everything we're
doing
so so common sense concepts and higher
level concepts are all
represented in the same way they're set
in the same mechanisms yeah
it's a little bit like computers right
all computers are universal turing
machines
even the little teeny one that you know
my toaster
and the big one that's you know running
some cloud server or some place
um they're all running on the same
principle they can apply different
things
so the brain is all built on the same
principle it's all about
learning these models structured models
using movement
and reference frames and it can be
applied to
something as simple as a water bottle in
a coffee cup and it can be right to
thinking like what's the future of
humanity
and you know why do you have a hedgehog
on your
on your desk i don't know nobody knows
i think it's hedgehog that's right it's
a hedgehog and the fog
it's a russian reference
you